yo
happy new year everybody what's going on
thanks for joining me
my name is clinton jones i am the
punisher and today
we are going to talk about looping
animations and how to get the perfect
loop i'm gonna teach you guys how to go
over uh basically that yeah how to get
the perfect loop
including uh randomly generated camera
shake
how to how to loop that perfectly which
was actually
a challenge but the solve was actually
not that bad so i'm excited to share
that with you guys
i'm going to talk about all the
different ways i got this thing to loop
how to loop the lighting
how to loop the objects in your scene
how to loop the camera movement
all that good stuff so this is what
we're doing today i think let's see
if i boom there we go okay so
this is a scene that i put together over
the last couple days
um over at corridor myself
sam and peter were all challenged with
creating a looping
simulated render we did one of these
videos a while back a few months back
and i have a breakdown um to that as
well a looping animations video but i
want to go a bit more in depth with you
guys and actually break down
this whole video
i learned a whole lot along the way
while doing this
and i'd love to get you guys started on
your own kind of renders
like this so this is going to be a
breakdown of this um
but it'll be an in-depth breakdown i'm
going to show you you know everything
that went into this
into this effect here into this little
animation
so yeah very very excited about that
um happy new year to all you guys thank
you so much for sticking with me
all of last year even though it was a
really crappy year um
and for everyone who's on this video
right now this is the first stream i'm
doing
this year so thank you so much for
coming back it means a lot
and it helps me do this every single
week um
you know a lot of work goes into this
stuff a lot of work goes into putting
these live streams together and they're
going to get better i promise you
all right i got my stream deck i'm going
to figure this stuff out all right i
hope
that every time i do a stream this year
i learned one or two things about the
stream deck and about obs
and about the whole stream situation i
want to get it looking nice
so that's one of my goals this year
also if you guys aren't a part of the
discord community i got my own discord
and it's full of a bunch of awesome
people most of you guys are on it
um but there's a whole there's a new
little
channel there called goals and i want to
check back in with you guys
on all of your goals so type them out
there and we'll hold each other
accountable
and we'll make 2021 a good year
regardless of what happens with the
chronovirus or whatever
let's make sure that we're still moving
forward so
all right y'all it's a good time welcome
everybody
welcome jw berry good to see you
um david welcome welcome
josh how's it going elle murray let's do
it
all right so here we are in cinema 4d
i hear if i freaking crunch look at this
freaking
oh here we go like i said guys i'm gonna
get better i'm gonna get better at obs
you're watching the jankiness happen
live but it's all good
you know we're having a good time okay
so here we are in cinema 4d and
first off you know this is the whole
scene this is everything
happening live
in the viewer here and it loops
perfectly there's going to be a little
lag
boop but it's going to come back and
it's going to loop now the first tip
to get this to play up to speed is to
uncheck the all frames button here
it's going to go really slow trying to
capture every single frame here
but if you want to play it in real time
in cinema 4d you just
hold down the little film strip uncheck
all frames and it'll play at
the the frame rate that you uh that you
set
which for me is 30 fps here all right so
how the heck do you even start doing
this thing
let's take a look at um let's take a
look at the video here
and see what's going on
um so you know there
are a lot of things that go into making
this thing
loop and look seamless
first we're going to note the fact that
all of the objects all of the singing
bowls which i'll get into later i'll
explain what that is in a second
but all of these singing bowls
are perfectly looping the floor is
perfectly looping the camera's perfectly
looping
um and you have these balls going
through so
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to break down how to set up
these objects how to model these objects
how to texture these
objects quickly how to hand animate
these little mallets
and how i get them to loop infinitely
and then how i'm animating these balls
to roll through
the concrete bits here um
so that's what we're that's what we're
gonna dive into here
now before we do that y'all i gotta give
a shout out to our sponsor on this video
the first sponsor of the year
is 3dexport.com um 3d export let me pull
this up for you all
is a place for you guys to go to
download your 3d models
or even your 3d models for printing too
they got a lot of cool stuff
and a lot of awesome models on this site
and i've used them in the past and i
think it's a really nice service let's
just check out like what they got
let's browse their 3d models real quick
they got some really good high quality
stuff for your renders
like this this tumbler here for 30 bucks
that's a steal
that's really nice but yeah i just want
to give a shout out to these guys
for sponsoring our stream who made this
one possible they look they got a
bosstown dynamics
spot robot for 60 bucks it's a good
price it's a very very good price
so you've got your print models if you
guys are into 3d printing
and cg textures if you guys are trying
to you know find some
different textures and everything they
got all this stuff going on here
and most importantly um
you know they got three free 3d models
because usually when i'm trying to model
something or when i'm trying to download
assets
the first thing i want to do is find the
best highest quality
free models possible so they have a
whole lot here you can see the list goes
on and on
um so you can probably just type in
whatever the heck you want see if they
got it for free
if not it'll probably be in the 3d
models little tab here
for a couple bucks they also have
tutorials too which is really cool um
it's like a one stop shop for anything
3d that you guys are looking for
so 3dexsport.com thank you guys
appreciate
the support and yeah go check them out
go check them out
let them know i sent you so
let's see here
wow like i said dang son
oh man i got to get better i got to get
better with this freaking uh
with this obs 3d export let me pull them
up for again pull them off for you again
boom here we go here we go son
yeah this this site's awesome it's a
good time
the 3d models they got a lot of good
stuff a lot of solid stuff here
very high quality reasonably priced give
them a check
check out their tutorials 3d vfx game
dev cinema 4d and their free models of
course
it's a good time check them out and
we'll check back in we'll see we'll see
what these guys are up to
all right so here we go
here we go let's figure this out
so the first thing that you guys
are going to notice here is
the placement of these bowls so
what i'm doing very let me let me
explain
in the easiest way possible i'm going to
make a new scene
and i'm going to create you know
a bunch of cubes here and i'm going to
just
kind of recreate what i did with those
bowls i'll just do it with cubes because
it doesn't
really matter what we're doing it with
um
so let's see let's just make a couple
cubes i'm going to hold ctrl
and what i'm doing here is just creating
kind of like an assembly line
of different cubes and whatnot
you can make this as elaborate as you
want
and this will essentially be
you know one piece of the puzzle that
we're going to duplicate
over and over and over again okay so if
i take my camera
and i go right above like we did
with those singing bowls and
i you know set this to 90 degrees
negative 90 degrees
so it's pointed straight down and it's
centered up and everything
let's change the z now what i'm going to
do is i'm going to make
a keyframe right at zero i'm going to go
to the last frame frame 72
and let's just go ahead and pull the
camera
down across all of this stuff
like this perfect so let's take note of
how far we're going let's go an exact
count
1 000 centimeters and we'll make another
keyframe
so now we have our camera moving at a
thousand centimeters
exactly and it goes back up to the top
now one thing to note if you hit control
d by default cinema 4d
will make bezier keyframes
meaning it's going to ease into the
motion and then ease out of the motion
let me let me show you what i mean so if
i were to quickly
hit shift f3 this is my dope sheet i'm
going to delete the keyframes
okay hit ctrl d that's going to bring up
our project settings and if we go to key
interpolation
the interpolation that i've set it to is
linear but if you set it
spline which it is set to by default
and you make those keyframes
and we go a thousand
you can see by default it's going to
speed up into it and slow down
into it now let me go ahead and start
duplicating
these cubes so let me hop out of the
camera and i'll show you guys how
that'll mess things up
so if i take all these cubes and i hold
ctrl
alt i'll click the cloner all those
cubes would be popped into the cloner
but it's doing it in a way that we don't
really want to clone these so i'm going
to select
all these cubes and hit alt g
and that's going to clone basically
the cubes how we had set them up so
we want we don't want a grid array we
want to do it linearly
and we want it you know three counts is
fine
but we don't want it on the y-axis we
want it on the x-axis
and remember how we move the camera 1000
centimeters
on the x-axis well we're going to clone
this at exactly
1000 centimeters as well so
now even though we have this box inside
of this box which we can totally fix
by maybe making the original box a
little smaller
and bringing it down just a little bit
we can go into our camera here and we'll
hit play
and it's kind of looping but we need the
boxes up at the top
as well so you can take the cloner and
you can offset it
so go to transform and we can move it
negative
1000 points now
it's going to loop but remember our key
frames
you can set you can hit ctrl d and set
the key interpolation
to linear so anytime you make a new
keyframe it's going to make
a linear keyframe as opposed to a spline
one hit shift f3
and we can select our keyframes and make
them linear that way
so now it should be a
perfect loop but you'll see a pop that's
because technically
what we're going for what we want is the
frame
one to match your last frame and you can
see here i'm going back and forth
between frame one and frame zero
and it's exactly the same which is
exactly what we want
from here you're going to have a
duplicated frame
so if you just play back 71 frames as
opposed to 72
it will perfectly loop
so that's how i'm looping
my objects and this linear camera
movement i'm making sure
that the distance i'm moving the camera
is the same distance
i'm cloning and then if i need to offset
that whole clone piece i'm offsetting it
negative 1000
right so
this way is we're able to make a very
very simple
loop like this so
where do we go from here the next thing
that i want to show you guys is you'll
notice there's
actually some subtle
camera motion um and some camera shake
to this animation and this was really
difficult to actually
figure out
but the solve was very exciting
so i want to show that to you guys
really quick
all right so
what i'm going gonna do it you can you
can do this a number of different ways
in cinema 4d
and it's going to be the same for
blender if you guys are in blender
the idea is that we want to
basically make a new camera i'm using
grayscale gorillas
gorilla cam so i'm going to make a new
camera right click it
give it the gorilla cam tag and you're
going to point this
this tag here it's looking for an input
camera boom you'll just throw in your
actual camera so now we'll hop into our
new camera
with the gorilla cam on it
and it's doing some craziness
so let's adjust these settings here um
let's choose a preset let's just choose
like uh
i don't know
basic um handheld
and it's kind of all over the place it's
a little intense and it is
ramping up into
um into that camera motion and i'm
wondering if
that's within the the camera settings
let me check
let's just check our gorilla cam
settings i want to get it so that it
doesn't ease into it let's take off the
jolt
system um
[Music]
because we don't want any jolting
in our camera movement this is a really
cool plug-in i i really like this
and let's do
all the smoothing smoothing and
overshoot i'm going to turn this down to
zero
all this stuff
there we go so now it's a linear
linear movement here so it's a little
intense i think
the rotation
is a little crazy
and i think the position slow is a
little crazy we want it to
stay centered
but you can see hopefully there's a
pop right at the end here
where the camera the camera shake resets
let me see if i can make this more
obvious to you guys
i mean it's pretty nice actually kind of
as
is
i'll make it obvious i'll crank up the
position medium maybe a little bit
position slow
there we go that's a good example so if
i crank up the position slow
you can see the obvious little pop here
and shift in the camera movement so to
fix this
here's what you got to do you basically
have to bake your your uh
your camera settings and your camera
movement down so
i'm gonna just quick bake it and now we
have these key frames
as opposed to it being randomly
generated because that's the issue is
being randomly generated the whole time
so let me go to my camera here i'm gonna
select my camera
and if i go to animate add motion clip
just hit ok by default
it's going to turn our keyframes into
basically like a layer that you would
see
in any editor you know like premiere
davinci or even after effects
you guys are used to this idea that it's
just like a layer here that you can trim
all that good stuff so
if we take our motion source and we drop
it in
we can slide it around so we'll have one
at the back
and then we'll have one at the end and
we'll make sure they touch
and literally that is all you need to do
ah but here's the other issue here is
the other issue
it's the the z data or the x data in our
case
it's going back and forth back and forth
and it's blending between
those two um you know that start
clip and the end animation it's going
between those two
we want to
before we make the motion clip
what you want to do so let's go back
let's go to animate add motion clip
okay and before
let's see let's see let me think about
this
before you make the motion clip what we
want to do
is delete
i believe the x position data
because the exposition data right here
is moving linearly
from top and we're scrolling down to the
bottom
we don't want to mess with that
we want that to be consistent so i'm
actually going to delete that
okay so now we just have
camera shake
just like this it's not scrolling
anymore
so what we'll do is we'll get that
motion clip now hit shift f3
to bring up our dope sheet
all right and we'll go into this motion
source view let's drag that in
so we have one and two
and now
it'll blend perfectly you can see
there's no
jump there's no pop that's it and then
all you need to do is basically
animate the the exposition so you can
drag this into our original camera that
has that data
whoa that looks crazy
very interesting okay so i didn't mean
for that to happen
but we just want to move the x let's see
let's find the right
go into world there we go so we want to
go negative 1000
on the x or positive 1000. so i'll make
a
frame here i'll go to the end and i'll
give this
to know what is it i'll put a 10 in
front of it
so it's 1013.
make another keyframe and hopefully now
it will work yep there it is
so basically all i did just to recap
um i baked down my camera shake
you can use um i think there's like a
wiggle or something or like a jiggle tag
or something like that
or a motion tag in cinema 4d that you
can do the same thing with
you want to bake down that data delete
your like
linear movement if you have linear
movement
you want to turn that into a motion clip
and then you take that
and you put one at the start one at the
end making sure they touch
and it'll be perfectly seamless so that
was a big breakthrough for me on how to
you know how to actually get the the
looping camera shake
i never knew how to do that so it was
cool it was it was a nice find
all right so let's go back and take a
look at
this looping animation i created
and see what other things we can take
out of this what what other things we
can learn from this
i'm going to get into modeling and
texturing very soon here
but let's see if there's anything else
that we can do ah
yes of course so lighting right i had to
light this thing
and have the light loop so the easiest
way to do that
is let's go ahead and render this
and save our scene
all right so let me just briefly set up
an hdri
let's get one of these going apartment
night
that's good
okay let me make a ground plane we'll
scale this way way up
and let me hop out of the camera here
and light it the same way i let the
original render okay so i'm going to get
this light
big old light from the side nice soft
light giving you some cool shadows
across the ground
and let's turn this thing up
why is it not doing anything
that's weird what's going on
being blocked or something oh duh
it's not pointing the right direction
all right all right way too intense
still way too intense
and let's just angle it down so we can
get some shadows or maybe we can bring
let's see
maybe we make a material for the ground
so it's not so bright and we'll make
like a
yeah let's maybe do like a dark color
and we'll make it glossy
and we'll crank the roughness up just a
bit
let me see if i can't make this more
obvious too so if you go to options and
uncheck the check camera option you can
hop out of your camera
and still keep the lights live still
keep your render view live
um let's see if i can't get in here and
make this super obvious
so the smaller your light the more
pronounced your shadows will
be
let me make yeah i'll make this real
obvious for y'all
so if we were to hit play even though
our scene
loops the lighting doesn't loop
obviously
because the light is at the top of our
scene and it's not tracking with our
camera so the easiest fix for this
you simply just have to put the light
in the camera make it a child of the
camera
and then when you hit play
your lighting is going to match
throughout the entire shot too
as you can see here it's going through
the lighting is tracking and again you
always want to make sure that your first
frame
looks exactly like your last frame
that's the whole thing right so
obviously when you put out your final
product you don't want duplicated frames
so you'll make your animation one frame
less
but if you can get the first frame
looking exactly like the last frame
you're golden that's the whole thing
that's what i'm always checking during
this whole thing
so let's go back to
the render and see what else we can get
out of this
now do you guys have any questions i'm
going to get into modeling
how i model these mallets very quickly
and how i textured the scene very
quickly as well
in a second but do you guys have
anything that you want to
you want to learn here
yeah you could you could throw in um
your objects into the cloner and adjust
it from there
so if i were to hop out of this and mess
with my cloner
it would move it in all instances
so you can really shape your scene like
this and come up with some cool shapes
this way and you can you can even add
more
as well i'm holding ctrl and dragging
and
and making different shapes and stuff
yeah so you really have full control
over it this way with the cloner now it
needs to be in a null object
it needs to be in a null object oh god
that's right god dang it
thanks guys i'm gonna figure this one
out
i'm such a noob when it comes to
streaming oh boy
um all good though yeah so
um you can totally mess with it in the
cloner
and adjust things and it'll keep moving
things for you
live it's a really easy way
to have full control over your animated
loops
you got to keep it in the null object
right here if it's not in the null
object it's going to clone it
in a different way it's going to choose
any one of
these cubes and clone it
based on the settings you have so it'll
clone it three times
but no we want all of this to be counted
as one thing
so you're cloning this null object with
all your cubes in it that's that's an
important little piece there
all right so um
let's see here let's go back to the clip
and see what we can see all right
so quickly i'm going to talk about the
modeling and the texturing of this stuff
real quick because that's a big part of
this
and it's a big part of why it looks so
real is specifically the texturing but
the modeling
also comes into play too all right
so let's go back
to our
how do we want to do this let's go back
to our main scene
cool
so i have a bunch of different bowls and
a bunch of different mallets i think i
have
maybe six or seven bowl types
and five or six mallet types
so let me talk to you real quick about
how i modeled
these mallets and these bowls very very
very
simply the bowls is
it's just a sphere and it's set to
hemisphere and let's see i think i can
set this to
now i just gotta flip it so i'm pressing
r holding shift to
snap on this onto the specific angles
here
and we got it at 180 degrees we'll give
it a couple more segments
and you'll notice if i were to render
this
it's just thin it's super thin right
let's uh let's get another hdri in here
i got a warzone pack let's open up the
warzone pack
and see which ones we can do uh
let's go to the sewers
and we'll get that down to linear
awesome okay
so you'll notice that the edge here is
obviously
flat we don't want that so i'm going to
select
all the faces well first i need to make
the sphere editable
select all the faces of the sphere and
we're going to hit d for extrude and we
need to make sure that create caps is
checked if it's not
then you're going to get basically
you know this kind of look and you you
still
want a face on the inside
so we'll create caps make sure that's
checked
drag it out just a bit and you know
there you got a bowl
but nothing has a perfectly sharp edge
in real life it doesn't exist
so we need to bevel these edges it's the
way i'm getting
this to like catch the light on the
edges like that
on the edges of the the bowls here
the only reason it's catching the light
like this is because the edge is beveled
so let's go ahead and
do this i'm gonna hold shift hold down
this little
modifier button here and we're gonna let
go on the bevel modifier
and you can see that it bevels our edge
let me get rid of
the work plane
and it's doing a nice little bevel on
our edge there
usually i go to at least three for
something like this especially if it's
like
you know obvious and close up
but by default you know cinema actually
checks the use angle button i think this
started happening in like r21 or 22. i
can't remember
if it's unchecked it's going to get
everything and that's obviously overkill
and it gives you a weird
kind of stepping look here that you can
see
we don't want that so we want to use the
angle threshold button
so it only gets angles that
that you tell it to so that's as easy as
that for the ball
all right for the mallet what i did
was you know i actually have one of
these things
um let me let me full screen this for
y'all
bam all right here we go
so this is a singing bowl
it's a tibetan bowl thing i don't really
know all the history about it
but i know they use it like for
meditation
and in yoga sometimes specifically for
meditation
it's also used to make music it's a very
satisfying thing here let me
let me test this for you guys
[Music]
and then you can
it's pretty chill they come in all
different shapes and sizes
make different tones different notes
and you know you can get a bunch of them
together and make some awesome
sounding chords i love ambient music so
that's
kind of why i was inspired to make
something like this
so um
it comes with this mallet now this
mallet right here
um is very very simple i look at this
i look at this and what's the first
primitive object that you guys think of
is it a square is it a sphere
hopefully it's a cylinder
hopefully you think cylinder when you
see this and yeah this glove is for my
tablet
um i have a wacom tablet down here
i use uh don't use a mouse and it allows
my hand to glide
over the tablet without getting stuck
with like my oils or anything
it keeps the tablet alive longer too
so anyway this mallet here
is very very simple it's a very simple
model
and i'm going to show you guys how i
created this
i'll show you the final
let's see if i can't just like copy
this guy mallets
right now let's open up let's open up
the thumbnail that i did
for this project um
where is the thump here hold on
i already have it open here we go i'll
grab this mallet
we'll bring it into our modeling scene
all right here we go
so the texture
on this is is very important to
making this thing look real and if you
get close enough you can really see like
it's kind of low poly you know but from
the angle that we're viewing it at
um let me let me get this big old head
down here
bam you know from the angle that we're
viewing it at you can't really tell that
these mallets are low poly
so it's very simple i'll go over
textures in a second but let's go over
the shape of this thing
let's hide that and let's just make it
from scratch here so i'm going to make a
cylinder
in c4d i'll move it over and i'm just
going to scale it down i
it helps to have the reference object in
hand so i'm going to take a look at this
thing
and i just want to model out
the like this little uh felt part
right so let's scale
this down let's do something like this
i'd say it's probably the dimensions of
that
we'll get it down here like this we can
always mess with the dimensions
but let's go ahead and add a couple more
segments to it
we'll hit c to make it editable now all
you're doing here
is basically just making some loop cuts
and doing some extrudes and some subtle
scaling
so here we go let me see if i can
prop this up here so this is the felt
part
you know it's just this felt part
then what we need to do is go to edge or
face mode
or segment mode i'm gonna hit ul that's
gonna do a
like a loop selection and then i'll hit
m w and that's going to extrude
enter it'll allow you to bring this face
in like this
all right and you know what even better
even better yet let's
let's do a better job of this let's just
hit d
we'll extrude the whole thing out this
will be the full length of the mallet
and i'm going to hit kl and that's going
to allow us to make
some cuts here so i'm going to make a
few we'll go
one
two
dang
let's see how many i'm just gonna count
how many rivets are in this one two
three four
five so i'll make five
cuts you can just do one two three four
five
two three four and five cool and you can
select all of these with ul in edge mode
so they're all equally spaced apart and
hit t and just scale them down on the y
and then move them down with w so we
have these five cuts down here
ul will get you with
the loop selection once again but this
time in edge mode
let's select these guys hit t and we
want to scale them in
but you'll notice actually what you
won't notice
now you will notice that they get scaled
in
and smushed together right we don't want
that
so we want to uncheck y scaling
so they just scale like this so it makes
sense the difference between this
and this
right so these aren't moving up and down
on the y axis because we unchecked it
perfect so then you can take that hit
u y and grow your selection
we could take all this select these guys
and just
crunch it down a little bit you can also
take this
and move these guys up just to shape it
and then take all of this
and move it down
so that's kind of like the base of our
mallet there now it does this thing
where it kind of bows in
like knuckles almost but let's get these
let's get these pieces up here to work
so let's do something very similar one
two three four five
all right and
we'll grab all this stuff we'll bring it
down
let's scale these guys in
oh we need to make a new cut so
kl will make you a cut there
we'll bring this guy down
we'll scale these guys in
and we'll scale these guys down
so it's really just shaping it selecting
your edges and
scaling things up scaling things down to
shape it properly
and then finally at the end it kind of
tapers off so
we can do something like that
one two three four
we'll scale that guy in and then we'll
do
a selection up here we'll scale this guy
in
something like that and finally you can
do
kl for the loop get that little piece in
there
and even just grab the point
and move it down
now we're almost there we almost have
our mallet
we just need to shape it a little bit
more so this is the felt part
um let's see if we can't
hit zero in cinema and that will
actually give you the tool
that cuts through all the pieces there
and it'll allow me to select the faces
in the back the points in the back
um and that's going to be your
rectangular selection tool
now from here i kind of want to
bow these in these two little wood bits
in so i'm going to hit kl
in edge mode if you hold shift it'll
snap
to these certain points and i want to go
right to the middle
and let's give it let's give it five
cuts
so that we have that middle slice right
there and i'm gonna do the same for up
here too
so i'm gonna go one one two three four
five
oop try that one more time
one two three four so five cuts in total
awesome now from here i can go to edge
mode
and select one
and two
and we wanna scale these down but we
want it to bring the other edges
with it so you're going to use the soft
selection you're going to enable soft
selection for that
and let's go ahead and bring the
strength down and i'll leave strength up
we'll bring
the radius down so like that
and you can see how it's kind of doing
what we want it to do
but the falloff is linear let's set it
to dome
that way it kind of gets that like
bamboo look
you know it bows in just like that
and the last thing we need to do is
bevel these edges
again because all edges are beveled
so select the cylinder and it's as easy
as holding down shift
which will make whatever we select an
automatic child
of this cylinder and we'll throw a bevel
modifier on it
it's a little too harsh making this
thing look like a donut
and we're not we're not doing blender
guru donuts right now so
what we want to do is set that offset to
like
point two give it three for subdivision
um maybe point four we could do on the
mallet yeah
that feels good so it's getting all the
edges you want
we could even open it up to get this one
too so you take the threshold and set it
to like
uh okay so the threshold is like 40 but
it's not getting that one so what we
could do
is uh we could technically
go to your edge mode go to ul for that
loop selection
right so we get that piece we'll make a
edge
selection all right so i made the button
custom up here
which you can do by well a lot of
different ways hit shift c
type in set selection
and you can drag this button up up here
in the cinema and save it out by going
to
a window customization and
you would save your layout as
um for me it's a startup layout i got
but we have that selection you can also
go to select
and set selection right here
we'll make another bevel modifier it's
doing all the same stuff
but we're going to uncheck use angle and
we're going to drop that selection into
set selection
now that's not right so
what we want to do is select our
cylinder hit control
a to grab all of these faces here and
hit
uo it's going to optimize it let's also
it looks like there's some weirdness
going on in here
let's align our normals so that's going
to be
a right click and align normals ua
i think there's like some weird geometry
stuff happening
down here um let's uh
let's try and and fix that so
okay it's doing some
some craziness in here
i don't know what i did to cause that
there we go
oh now it's just working okay that was
just a that was just an
error some weird modeling error that i
ran into there
okay so now that
we have our mallets textured basically
what i'm doing here is i'm just
texturing and modeling a bunch of
different style mallets
you know you can see smaller ones this
one here has like a wider
like felt piece it's the same one this
one's just made of wood
it's a bit more simple this is just a
duplication of this
the tiny mallet is a more simplified
version of this here but it's all made
of wood
and i found all these just by going to
google and looking up different mallet
types
so that was my process for modeling this
stuff
now let's get into texturing so to
texture these
my biggest secret is i did not
texture everything custom i didn't make
my textures from scratch
because i didn't have the time it was a
you know basically again myself
sam and peter were all tasked with
making a satisfying render at corridor
in a couple days now monday we have to
deliver and show our renders
luckily um you know
i was able to finish mine in time i bit
off a bit more than i could chew last
time
but i had to get smart with the way i
textured this stuff
i couldn't have done all this stuff
manually
so what i did was use grayscale gorillas
material packs and they actually um if
you guys
know if you guys know um
you know my channel and all the streams
that i've done
you guys will know that i love grace go
gorilla and i actually did a sponsored
stream
with them i think in december last year
they came out with their new plus
service
and it's all hooked up in the cinema so
well so nicely
so i definitely took advantage of all
that
so they have a pack called the everyday
materials collection
and it's all just a bunch of like
pre-made textures
that look sick and these were the ones i
used to texture
the singing bowls specifically like the
gold the copper and the bronze
the smudged ones with the scratches and
stuff
yeah it looks it looks super nice so let
me just take brass
worn and
drop it on the bowl and you'll see
like by default it's looking really good
it's looking super nice so i think the
these little bumps are popping off of
the model
and i want them to get pushed into the
model so i think i need to just
reverse my normals
so we don't want a
soft selection right now so i'm gonna
hit you are reverse my normals
and those dents will be more like
scratches indented
into the actual bowl another way you
could do that because technically
these are proper normals you can go into
the material
and i'll go to the node editor and you
can just
invert whatever is causing um
the indentations in this case the normal
so we can invert the normal
and then it'll work properly with the
proper normals
hopefully that'll make sense now one
thing that i notice here
that does not look good are these
stretched edges
you can really see up on the edge of
this thing and that's just
the way this thing is mapped maybe i
could unwrap this but i don't know much
about it
so what i'm doing is essentially
just changing the way i'm wrapping the
texture around the sphere
so i'll select my material here up in my
objects window
excuse me and you'll notice that you
guys have like
um your attributes panel pops open
and projection is an option that you can
choose so uvw
mapping is by default but what if we set
it to cubic
now by setting it to cubic it'll
actually
map this thing a bit more accurately
across this bowl
and you'll notice that you get you know
the proper uh the proper mapping across
the edge of this thing too
now i am seeing some like harsh lines in
here just because we are
using cubic mapping across a sphere
so what you can do in cinema is select
your material
and then select this little uh material
box here
and it'll allow you to move your texture
around your your your model
and get a more accurate or just a
different look
so i can mess with this until those
lines go away you can also scale it up
and try and find something that
that feels right another thing you could
do is
you could you could essentially um
bake down the sphere and say hey i want
uvw mapping
on the inside and the outside of the
bowl but just on the top
and these little beveled pieces i want
cubic mapping
so you can use that or you can do that
with like the whole set selection thing
so let me show you real quick how to do
that
so if i were to break down
this bevel with the sphere i'll right
click it and connect
objects plus delete that just bakes it
all down
so i'll get rid of both of those
materials and i want to
go into uh polygon mode here
and let's select everything
except this for this like top little rim
and the easiest way to do that is hit ul
get the loop selection going
and if you hit u y that is going
to grow your selection you see that it
grows it
and we'll go one more time and let's set
that selection again i made the custom
button or you can go to
select set selection
all right so from here
we want a we want another selection but
on everything
else so the easiest way to do that is to
invert the selection i think ui is the
hotkey yep
and you get everything else and we'll
set that selection oh
but we don't want to we don't want to
set the selection with the current
selections
selected god that is confusing so undo
and we'll just click off of it and then
make a new one so this one is called
bowl and this one is called
rim
so if we double click we have those
different ones right
so we noticed that just uvw mapping
looked a little bit better on the inside
and the outside of the bowl
so i want to set that to the bowl
not the rim of the bowl there you go so
you're dragging this little tag
into the selection box here
now we'll duplicate the material
and we'll apply it to the rim
so it's hitting the rim but you're
getting that nasty edge right the
stretchy
streaky edge which we don't want so this
is where we change it to cubic
and there you go it looks perfect
best of both worlds using the set
selection tags
so that's how i did the bowl you know um
grayscale gorilla
their plus library is absolutely
incredible and i went through and i just
found a bunch of ones that i thought was
like
super cool right so i think there's like
a
hammered copper in here yeah so i can
just drag this
onto my model
and it looks super cool and you can you
know get your selection things going
ctrl drag set it to cubic and put it on
the rim
and it's just it's just awesome like the
possibilities are endless
with their texture packs um let's go
ahead and invert that
yeah that looks proper awesome
awesome so for this here i'm actually
using grayscale gorilla
as well um but they came out with a new
pack their
tech products pack and they actually
have a felt
something like they have a headphone pad
but i think they have laptop fabric here
we go laptop fabric
so it's the same deal you know i'm just
getting that selection ul for loop
selection
getting all that drag it on there
and there you go you have a nice felt
material that perfectly matches
the my actual you know mallet here for
my singing bowl
it looks super nice it looks super nice
um you can do the same for the wood so
i'm selecting all this other stuff here
or you know we'll do the smart way
select everything and then hit ui to
invert it
so you select everything else and then
same deal
you know just going with a wood texture
the bevel
is throwing it off so
what you could do um
how did i do it on the original oh i
just baked it down so i baked again like
i did with the bowl i baked it down
because the bevel modifier it adds extra
polygons
and it kind of messes with the way your
materials are
are mapped out here
but yeah very simple very very simple
same idea i just did that for all the
rest of the mallets so that's how i
textured quickly
is using grayscale gorillas materials
and their different packs to make it
super easy
let's see um i want to give
another uh another shout out another
proper shout out here
to our sponsor 3d export
dot com um big thanks to these guys
for sponsoring this episode making this
stream possible this week's stream
possible
if you guys are looking for 3d models or
any of that good stuff if you guys are
looking for textures or even tutorials
on how to do all this
they have it for you at 3dexport.com
they even got
free models too that's really what i
look for is free models when i'm trying
to get something quick
they got a volvo and it's free
and it looks really nice it's awesome
so yeah give them a check go to
3dexport.com
um tell them that uh yeah tell them i
sent you and say
thanks hopefully they they help you guys
with your workflow
and allow you guys to do some cool stuff
and make things easier and save you guys
time
i know they have with me in the past so
shout outs
shout outs all right guys where where
are we at here
what else do we need to talk about the
ground um
is just a simple wood texture from
from bridge qixel bridge
you download those really easy let me
let me show you guys
if if anyone's new to all this i know
it's a lot
so let me let me just show you so
there's a
a service called qixel and they
are like the best when it comes to
packing a bunch of assets into one place
they make it really easy
so they have this program here called
bridge that allows you to
select materials or 3d assets and bring
them into your scene
super fast so let's go to
favorites here and i think i have that
wood texture or rather let's go to
purchased
oh the infamous pickle we'll go to
surfaces
and it was wood
here we go so you can select it
and you literally just hit uh
hit export and it's successfully
exported
and now it should pop up here it's
generating
it's going to pop up in our scene
give it a minute octane because
it could also be crashing right now it's
probably likely
oh no but there it is all right so if i
make a plane
and we'll hide i'll move the bowl on top
and we drop the wood down we can scale
it
up
and it's super nice looking by default i
like to bring it in
as glossy and octane
yeah there you go got a nice wood floor
and it's really easy to just bring in
their
materials it's super sick so that's what
i did for the wood
for the concrete i used grayscale
gorilla's
everyday materials pack to get that nice
concrete look
um i think the last thing we need to
talk about is
how i animated the mallets
and how i carved out the path for the
balls to go down
and also let me while we're on the topic
of texturing let me
talk about how i textured those
those chrome spheres and how i made them
look scratched and smudged you probably
can't tell in this example because it's
kind of low res and they're going quick
across the screen
but let me show you guys this is
actually really fun for me it's my
favorite process
and that's surface imperfections i made
a pack
of 30 surface imperfections they're all
16-bit
um and they're seamless they're tileable
they're 4k 2k 1k versions source
versions all that stuff and if you don't
know what i'm talking about
um then let me show you what surface
imperfections are
and if you want to check out the pack um
there's a link in the description down
below
all right so to make a chrome material
in octane
i just make a glossy material you can go
to uh
materials here and make a octane glossy
material
and we'll go down to index and we'll set
that to 1
and now it's perfectly reflecting the
environment
but it's too perfect that's the issue
and that's where the surface
imperfections come in
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
open up that material
let's hop in here and if you can't find
it
go to view frame all and there you go
what i want to do is like
you saw with the singing bowl with the
scratches i want to scratch
put some scratches into this thing right
so
you can use the bump channel to do
exactly that and it'll
it'll cheat the program that'll cheat
cinema 4d and octane
into thinking there's actual geometry
there that's being pushed down
but really there's not so you're saving
a lot of time
a lot of computing power and a lot of
data by doing it this way we're going to
use
an image in the bump channel
and let's go ahead and navigate to
my imperfection pack we'll go 4k why not
and i got you know it's just 30. i don't
want it to be
too heavy-handed you know i think
there's a lot of there's a lot of good
ones out there but
my biggest gripe is there's just too
many you know
i only use a handful really
and i just wanted to make sure that this
pack only had the hits
you know so let's go ahead and grab
the subtle scratches here
and there you go you can see some nice
subtle scratches going across the top of
this thing
let's um let's make this larger for you
all so you can see it a bit better
all right so the first thing i'm seeing
is it's a bit um
it's a bit intense okay so one thing we
can do we can take the power
and take it to like point one instead
or what you can do and i don't know if
this does the same thing
but what you can do is actually give it
you'd pipe the image texture into a
multiply node
nothing will change but it's texture 2
set to a float node that does the change
the float node is just a scale from
zero to one or in this case we can go
two and three
and really make this 50 you know we can
make it really intense
or we make it subtle which is what i
want to do so i'm setting this to 0.2
to make it kind of subtle right and i
want to
increase the amount of of scratches
so the reason that these textures are
16-bit
is so i can change the gamma and
maintain
all the data possible now it looks like
the bump
is popping up i want it to get indented
in
so we need to invert the texture and
that way
it's actually getting indented the gamma
is
too intense and it's messing with our
roughness so we can just set it to like
1.75 is fine from here i want to add
some more scratches so i could either
use another scratch texture
or i could duplicate this one scale it
up and rotate it
and let's let's do that
so i'm going to take all this ctrl drag
it up
and now i have these two instances right
so what i'll do is
let's go ahead and grab a mix node and
it's going to mix between
these two textures
i'll pipe it in here and nothing will
change because it's
literally they're on top of each other
um what i'll do here is go
to this image i'll give it a transform
node
and i'll just rotate it so it's giving
me
a different look on top of the scratches
that we currently have and i can also
scale it down so i'll go like 0.5
and we'll scale it down maybe 0.25 you
just don't want to see it looping
but i think that's actually pretty nice
maybe 0.35
so you get some nice scratches in there
now another thing
is this ball will probably be picked up
by you
a number of times so let me let me turn
off the bump we
will pipe that back in all right let's
go and mess with the roughness
so what the roughness does is it kind of
washes out
and blurs out the reflections so you'll
get this kind of look
but we don't want it uniformly across
the whole thing we want it just where
our fingerprints would touch it
so that's why i'll drop in
[Music]
a smudge texture that i made these were
the hardest to make
this these like monitor smudge textures
were the hardest to make
i got a whole video breaking down how i
made these
um on my channel it's like one of the i
don't know i can't really link to it
at this second but it's called uh
custom 3d textures full process or like
a
full uh full workflow or something like
that it's the one with my hands like
touching the
touching the poster board so let's go
ahead
and try one of these images and see what
we can get
now it's very very subtle at first
so the first thing i'll do i want to
wrap this around the sphere in a
specific way so projection node let's
bust that out and we'll set it to box
which is the same thing as like
cubic i'll give it the transform node
and let's go ahead and right click it
and solo it so we can see what's going
on
all right now we have these like edges
because of the way
the cubic mode um
uh like separates these things even
though they're seamless it's just the
way
box mode works so maybe what i'll do is
i'll go back to mesh uv
i think this is totally fine for what
we're doing
now that's not bad that's not bad at all
so our data is there it's just a little
subtle so we can actually take the gamma
and go set it to one and then it'll
really shine through here
and you'll get a nice smudgy look
on your chrome ball and you got your
fingerprints in there
good stuff really really nice a lot of
detail in these imperfections
we'll bring the bump back in
for the whole thing now they're a little
heavy-handed
so maybe i'll i'll take this transform
and i'll scale this down
as well 0.6
and then we can take these float nodes
instead of 0.2
we can go to like 0.05 so they're very
subtle
but when viewed from a distance like
it's a nice
it's a nice little bit of detail let me
compare for you so compare
we'll store the render buffer i'll go in
here i'll take off all the imperfections
and you tell me which one you like
better
so without and with without and with
god does this thing goes like it's all
crazy you get the point you get the
point
yeah so that's the way i use my
imperfections
to you know make the sphere make this
little ball seem uh
not as perfect and another trick
that i'm doing to actually give it this
like
glowy look if you notice there's kind of
like a glowy look to everything
the way these balls move towards the
light and everything there's a nice
like diffusion across all this stuff and
what i'm doing for that
is actually using um so i'm using cinema
or
technically octane's camera imager tag
so camera imager by default is unchecked
if i check it
you get all these awesome camera options
um
let's go with like kodochrome 25 it's
just a lut that you can drop
in um the saturate to white
slider it'll actually make things like
in this case it's not working but
if i bring a light in and i set the
light color
to i don't know
like 200 yeah yeah that's a perfect
example
in real life that light would not look
red
it's gonna look white so that's what the
saturate to white slider does
i found that point two gets me exactly
what i'm going for
but in this case since it's so intense
you can crank it up
so that that turns uh
the light itself turns white even though
it's a red light
the source will be white
so that's what that does um but i'm
talking about the glow
so post-processing we'll check that and
it's going to be
bloom power we'll crank that and then
we'll crank the cut off so it's only
getting the brightest points
and then you have glare power
which you can just set the glare amount
to one so you just have like one little
streak but then make that really subtle
you really don't want that to be too
intense
it can be very very subtle and the angle
of course controls
you know the angle of the glare but i
use that a lot i use that in every
render i do it adds like a nice
you know natural look to things i'll
also throw a vignette down too
that helps things depending but usually
i'll throw a vignette down and the
highlight
you can save the highlights by cranking
the slider and i'll always do that
so that's how i'm making it look really
nice how to make it look real
um yeah and then i'm just doing using
dynamics to get the ball to slide down
this little tube
and that's basically it so i'll show you
guys my little dynamic setup
and quickly how to animate these mallets
so how how's everybody doing are you
guys doing right give me some thumbs up
here
if you guys are hanging in there if
you're learning a lot oh snap
yo chris what's up dude
hey thank you for the super chat um
happy new year
for for your super chat chris i'm
actually going to pop off this little
popper
but i'm not going to do it in the mic
all right because that would be
very bad i'm going to go way back here
and i'm going to pop this off for you
so thank you for the super chat
appreciate it watch your ears just in
case i don't know
i don't know who knows how this is gonna
go
good times good times
i wish i could get all hyped on it you
know and just do it right here right in
the camera
but i think that would be uh it'd be bad
for you guys
all right so rylan is listening watching
and sculpting along
this time sculpting analog or sculpting
along
and probably sculpting along good times
everybody
background while you're working heck
yeah
sweet awesome awesome good times
everybody
yeah we got thumbs ups
yo prop proplayer08 it is i
indeed thanks for thanks for coming down
thanks for watching the vid
yeah we're learning lots of stuff we're
doing cinema 4d live streams
every single week this whole year
hopefully we'll get oh snap happy new
year revolver
merry christmas um happy new year here's
another
super chat popper it's going over this
way because
you know i don't want to redline this
thing it'd be bad
now that
that may have been an ear bleeder
but you know that's what happens when
people doing super chats
you know it's we gotta we gotta set off
poppers at least today
was that too loud or was that fine
because i saw a red line on my side
let me know y'all let me know john's
setting up renders
rich crazy dad just just it just got
done watching vfx arts react video
found this by accident fantastic
fantastic
not loud enough all right i'll do it
right right into the mic
just right here just right into the
camera
josh heck yeah dude
what up yo you get you a party popper
for you man
happy new year good times watch your
ears if they're sensitive
three two one oh
you know i like this i like this party
popper situation every time a super chat
we get a
little party popper it makes it fun or i
could just do a little party popper
thing on the screen
maybe that'll be better too loud
i'll back up next time all right
so let's
do it in the mic next time heck no
that'd be horrible okay um
do the balls need motion blur yes they
do you are correct
um who said that ian
they totally do now this isn't my final
render this is a low-res version the
final render is about halfway done and
i'll continue the render once i'm done
streaming
and i made sure to include the uh
made sure to include the motion blur on
that one
uh yeah i got a lot to learn streaming
wise i'll put on the pop filter next
time we'll see
okay
um pop one or popple uh
yeah the floor i made with uh well i
didn't make it i downloaded it
from qixel bridge very easy very very
easy very simple
okay
david that is a good idea
i have to make a party popper from
scratch every time someone super chats
no i'll do a 3d version maybe that's
that's what i'll do i think that's nice
that'll be really fun
all right here we go
let's let's wrap this up let's wrap this
little lesson up here so how am i
animating
um i might not make that mistake again
how am i animating this mallet
to endlessly loop around this ball all
right so
here's what i'm doing let's go ahead and
move the ball up
let's get this ball and scale it down it
looks cool so i'll leave it in the scene
just get it right on the floor there
so let's take the mallet and let's reset
its rotation and we'll bring it
like right right above
this guy here okay so we want to
probably scale it down make sure our y
scale is checked
we'll scale it down and we want to get
this thing like right on the edge here
angled this way a little bit and just
right on the edge
wonderful
and for those of you guys just joining
this is um this is a render
that i built um for for corridor me
sam and peter are challenging each other
to come up with satisfying renders
and the video i believe will drop
wednesday so definitely check that out
um i can't wait to see
sam's render and peter's render i don't
know what they got in store
um and you know we'll show you guys how
you know how to do everything i'm going
really deep into into detail on how i
did this
um which you won't get in that episode
but you do get you know all of us
goofing off
creating it and giving you the breakdown
it's the quick version
of all of our renders and it's all of us
having a good time i'm sure you guys
know at this point
how it is over at corridor so definitely
check that out it's coming out wednesday
i believe
satisfying renders too all right so
let's animate this thing around this
bowl
um let's go ahead
and put the mallet in a null object so
alt g
with it selected and i'm going to move
the anchor point i'm checking this
little box here the enable axis tool
so we can move the anchor point and
let's just set it to zero because that's
center of the bowl we can hit l to
disable
the uh the axis tool and let's go ahead
and hit n a
that way we can turn off our lines
i'm going to hit r and we want this to
go around the bowl
infinitely alright so if i were to set
my
scene to 500 frames
and i make a keyframe with the null with
the rotation selected i make a keyframe
and i move forward
64 oh what happened
i think it's because my mallet okay
because it
i got you there we go all right so let's
try again
so i'll make a keyframe um for the null
object that the mallet is in
i'll go to frame 64. and i'll do a full
360 holding down shift to snap
on the 5 degree angle marks there make
another keyframe all right so we have
this thing going around the singing bowl
let's pause the render
and it stops
that's super lame it stops right there
so we want it to go endlessly it's very
easy
shift f3 that pulls up your dope sheet
that's going to be where all of your
keyframes are
okay so we just made one
and two and we want this to loop
endlessly across the entire
you know forever okay so select those
keyframes
select the null and go to functions
track after
and repeat after that will give you this
dialog box over here in your attributes
manager
you can set that to two times
and you can see hopefully
yep how it's repeating you can see it
repeat repeat
it'll repeat twice so once
and that's that's one repetition and
that's the second but it's going to stop
so all i'm doing is just setting it to
like 99
repetitions 99 and it'll just go on
forever and ever and ever
so that's how i'm getting that um
so very very simple there the last thing
is the animation of the ball
all right so
i'm giving this thing a let's go ahead
and move this
up so it's dynamics right if you guys
don't know how to do
cinema 4d dynamics you can you know
google and
youtube whatever and figure out anything
these days
but this is cinema 4d dynamics
what i want to do is essentially give
the plane or the floor
i want i want the ball to fall and
bounce on the floor
all right so the easiest way to do this
is to right-click the sphere go to
simulation tags and give it a rigid
body tag by default we hit play it falls
through the floor why the heck did it
fall through the floor because we wanted
to interact with the floor so we need to
right-click the floor go to simulation
tags and give it a collider body
it's going to be dynamic it just won't
be affected by gravity
so you'll see the ball fall and bounce
and land on the ground
just like that
you can change the settings and you can
make it like uh super bouncy
so the balance you can take to like 50
or even a hundred percent
and it'll just bounce and have a good
time
so if we can do that then maybe we can
set up a ramp
you know maybe we can do like a
another another plane
and we select one of the edges
and we hold ctrl and drag it up yep and
then we can bevel this edge
so ms is your bevel tool and give it you
know like 10 subdivisions
and maybe we move this
plane right over here
and we give this plane a collider tag as
well
so i'll copy it from the from the floor
oh and it just blasts it across
so the reason it blasted across is
because this plane
actually the shape of it it's reading
the shape as an actual box
we don't want that we want the shape to
be a static mesh
meaning like a bowl
this ball will not land in a bowl unless
the bowl
tag the shape is set to static mesh
that way it reads the fact that it
actually has like
some concave attributes to it then it'll
actually work you see that
boom so
you know i just set up a very simple
little like
little pipe setup for
these little concrete bits
right for it to slide down so i just did
like a little simple pipe
setup for that which is basically
a spline
um let's do yeah this is fine the arc is
fine
we'll lay it down holding down shift
i need to make give this geometry so
let's make a
circle spline we'll scale it down and
we'll select both of those
we'll hold ctrl alt and that way
whatever
we select in this case
a sweep um a sweep modifier
it's going to include both of those so
by holding ctrl
alt it puts both of these as children
so there you go and i'm using this
sweep right here if i were to
scale up the arc
all right i scale up the arc
something like that and i give the plane
maybe a bit of our ground plane
give it some depth some thickness
then i can use this sweep to cut out
the ground plane right so that's what
i'm doing for the concrete ground there
um so i'll take the sweep here
and our plane
and i'll use a bull to
cut that out so it's going to be a minus
b
just like that
and we'll create a single object
and apply the material to the top now
the mapping is a little off
so you just need to adjust the mapping a
little bit but that's how i'm cutting
into the concrete essentially
and then i'm using this sweep
as like a boundary as walls
for the ball so if i go back to my
original scene
you can see that i'm cheating i have
these little like bobsled
little like wall pieces here um let me
hop out of the camera view
you see that like these little shoots
and these little shoots are set to
collider bodies
but they're invisible in the render
obviously as you can see
so um all you need to do there
is check check this little box right
here or this little light
and let me see let me see if i can give
you guys the best example of this
give me a second while this renders
and that'll be it
good times very good times
so yeah that's about it that's about the
process originally i started out with
something
way too ambitious it was like this guy
going through this cave with a bunch of
crystals and he was
pulling a mine cart and the crystals
were being put pulled into the mine cart
with like this magnetic force it was
just going to be way too much so i
simplified and went with this instead
very happy with how it turned out the
full quality render i'll post on my
instagram
probably either monday or wednesday
we'll see
depending but yeah you can see in the
render
um obviously you can't see this little
tube that's because
this little light right here it's very
tiny but this
there's a little red light now you can
see the tube here
but if i turn on that red light
it's going to turn it off in renderer
the top one turns it off in viewport
that's what those lights are and if you
hold alt
you can turn them both on and off at the
same time
but we want it on in the viewport and
off
in the renderer and that's it guys
that's
that's it that's how i got this uh
this whole thing here it was a good time
thank you guys for uh for stopping by
and checking out this breakdown it's a
very
in-depth detailed breakdown once again
um
this video where myself uh
peter and sam all challenge each other
to make a satisfying render it comes out
on wednesday
um so stay tuned for that on
corridor digital it'll be a good time
now you guys know let me go ahead and
minimize this let me full screen this
y'all see the jankiness one day i'll
have this set up to like you know
my actual thing all right here we go
here we go let me turn down the iso
it's a little bright
all right so now comes the time
uh when we announce the five winners
of last week's weekly challenge which
was
new year's the challenge prompt was new
year's if you guys have ever done like
inktober
or anything like that you guys will be
familiar with the idea that you'll get a
prompt and you have to draw something
based off that prompt in this case we do
it every single week
and it's a pr it's a prompt that you
must render
um so the prompt was new years
the prompt for this week we're gonna
figure out after i announce the five
winners all right
so i know you guys love it when i uh
when i
review everything but it just takes so
long
i'm gonna try and figure out a way to do
that though all right because i think
it's very valuable to review
everyone's work and to give everyone
good feedback so i'm gonna figure that
out and figure that one out for you guys
um okay so
let's talk about these winners um you
guys always deliver amazing stuff
um and it's all done through the discord
so i have the discord link
join the community down in the
description below
and you guys can enter yourself it's
really fun it's a good way to learn
and last year we actually put together
a really cool render montage that you
can find on my channel here
and it did so well man it like it hit
1.2 million views
very quickly and it was the coolest
thing that i'd done in a very long time
and it it wasn't just me it was all you
guys too
it was a montage of everyone's best
environment work it was a
it was a contest with nvidia and pny and
i really want to do another one
asap so definitely subscribe if you guys
are not subscribed already and want to
join the next render montage i want to
include everyone's best work
and i want to spend some solid time on
it all right
um so let's uh yeah let's talk about
these winners
so a lot of you guys submitted
and there's a lot of good ones and it's
always difficult it is always difficult
to decide
um decide who wins this thing
all right okay
so let me let me squish my face down
into the corner again
so the first winner we have
is copperbot
with this image now this image is not
only an image
all right it actually came with a video
so i might as well just hop
right to the video and show you guys how
awesome this is
let me do i have to find it somewhere
where is it so many tabs
bam all right let's check it out
now apologies if there's sound it's
another thing i'm going to figure out
this year
how to get sound on here
so again the prompt is new years and if
you're paying attention
you'll notice that it's new years and
there's fireworks going on
outside and it's on the tv but you know
this dude here i don't know why he looks
russian
um he you know he's just a sad boy
he's not having a good time i think this
is awesome
a lot a lot of solid work went into this
a couple
um critiques if i if i may
let's go ahead and re-do that
so a couple critiques first
critique is the dude's proportions he
looks a bit emaciated
maybe you're going for that but maybe
not i don't know
um yeah he just looks like really skinny
like bones
you know um if that
is the point that maybe there's a couple
things you could do
to like point to that being a thing
um he definitely seems depressed
you know he's not out on new year's he's
by himself
and uh yeah so that's the first thing i
noticed is like
it's just super super skinny
and then okay so you went for that cool
i got you i got you
i definitely noticed yeah i definitely
noticed i'm wondering if there's like
things
like other small things you could do to
allude to the fact that
he is emaciated like why
why is he is he depressed which she
seems that way
um but maybe i'm just thinking too too
hard about it like
if you went for that then i think it's
good i definitely get the vibe that this
dude is like
not having a good time um
the yeah
that's really it that's really it
originally i was gonna say
i wish i wish the scene would have gone
somewhere which sounds harsh
um so you know don't take it harshly
what i'm trying to say is i i wish that
like there would have been an a
to a b kind of situation like what is
the point of the shot why does the shot
exist
now you're definitely getting the
emotion out of me um
with your scene here which is good and
that may have been your only goal and
you've achieved that
but you see he looks at the camera and
he like gets up and
and walks you know starts to walk away
or something
but like what if he was like deciding
you know this year i'm going to turn
things around
and you know he went to go for his first
bite of food or something
i don't know i don't know but that's all
i'm trying to say
with the extra little bit but i think
this is great this is fantastic so
congratulations copperbot
um or rita read off paul
um
[Music]
you are a winner this week i think you
won last week too man your renters are
really good
they're they're looking really nice
where have you been last year dude
welcome and congratulations you will
keep the
challenge winner roll for this week but
for this week
only all right number two
here we go so
all right let's uh let's figure this out
let's figure this out there's i have six
here
and i can only do five i'll get down to
the last two
in a minute though but next up we have
visual
and visual wins these a lot because man
his renders
are really good the quality is
always nice look at these surface
imperfections here too
absolutely incredible and you got this
person being printed out of this machine
super cool very very very cool like your
renders are amazing
the ideas you come up with are
incredible and look at the detail on
this plastic wrap
like that is hard to do that is really
nice
i love this i feel like i can touch it
new year new you i guess that's the you
know that was the
the inspiration 2021 right here written
now i would have flipped these around
probably so i could have read it a
little bit
more but otherwise this is amazing i
love your colors they're like cyan and
with the yellow and orange like that's
so nice
i love this so so much
yeah good stuff yeah that's visual very
nice render man
congratulations you are keeping your
challenge
winner role uh for this week and this
week only unless you have to earn it
next week you usually do you usually
hang on to it
next up we have
karimi karimi i love this look at this
this is so good i also just noticed
in the background there's like a
destroyed city
but you're headed towards that new year
that's so cool i love it it's a really
cool um
way to visualize the prompt of new
year's
i think this is just awesome good work
on the motion blur good work on the
lighting good work on the texturing the
rendering quality everything is great
everything is nice i love this so much
it's different and it feels really cool
so congratulations
karimi you are a challenge winner this
week you get the challenge
winner roll for this week only
um you have to knock out the next one
too to keep it so congratulations
and you know i just realized it'd be
really cool to like do some sort of like
stats recap of all the winners from last
year
how many times they won and everything i
think that would be kind of special
i have so many ideas for the for you
guys for the community for the channel
um for the discord and i just gotta
i gotta do them all i gotta figure out
how to do everything
but yeah congratulations creamy i think
this is awesome
very good stuff very good stuff
all right the next winner
that we have is jason bornvida
with this awesome render right here i
love this
this is really really good fantastic
render quality
very nice just what happened to the
bench you got to texture the bench dude
but regardless this is super sick i love
it
you got the chronovirus taken out 21
yeah 2021 is taking out this chronovirus
right here specifically in the eyeball
that's rough i love the tag
good stuff man really good stuff good
texturing good lighting
really nice quality i see you added like
a nice little film green to it good
texture on the little
little virus cells here
this pepto-bismol looking uh
two shapes and everything
this is great yeah this is really nice i
feel like this could be an animated
short
like a little pixar intro or something
so congratulations
jason bourne vida for winning the
challenge
this week you got the challenge winner
roll and uh keep it up man good stuff
very good stuff i look forward to what
you do in 2021
and finally it's between two renders
okay
it's between one
dead duck and fruit juice all right
it's between these two now i like a lot
of things about
both of them there's a lot of cool stuff
oh let me get this
here we go yeah there's a lot of good
stuff about both of these um
that i really like
but you know like technically the render
quality is better in this one
i love the balloons i really enjoy the
balloons
and it's a cool concept and uh
i think at the end of the day i gotta go
with fruit juice though you know even
though
there's a little bit of pixelation and
noise and stuff
i just love the feeling and again guys
i'm the only judge on these
i know some of you may disagree with my
choices sometimes and that's okay
the whole point is that you know i want
to give recognition to everybody
i want to give recognition to the
community and i want you guys to learn
and grow
alongside each other all right so that's
the whole point of all this
um but the reason i chose this one is
because i really
really like the feeling of it it reminds
me of
the time i was in taiwan and i went to a
place
called joe fun i think is the name i'm
totally butchering it
but it's the place that um miyazaki
based
spirited away off of and i remember
having a very similar moment like this
and instead of fireworks it was lanterns
and we were having tea
so this one is very personal for me i
love the feeling of it it really
it makes me feel a lot i'm just you know
sad that i'm seeing all the noise and
stuff back here i don't really know
exactly what's going on it looks like an
image or a picture was just thrown in
maybe you could have no you did i you do
have the focus on the main character
the background's blurred out i can't
tell if you did it with the in-camera
um depth of field or if this was just
like photoshopped i can't tell
but i love it man it looks really nice
so congratulations
um to fruit juice for winning the
challenge this week you're getting the
challenge winner roll
hang on to it all right hang on to it
your stuff is really nice it's been it's
been really good and i think you've
joined the server
a few months ago so welcome harrison
harrison with the kombucha money i
appreciate you uh
saying thanks i really appreciate the
super chat it means a lot and it helps
me do more of these
i got a party popper for you right here
so i'm gonna pop this off
and then i'll say my goodbyes all right
so watch your ears everybody i'm gonna
go back here and i'll set this one off
for harrison
thank you
it scared my fiance on that one good
times
very good times all right
all right happy new year everybody
good work thanks for putting on uh
for putting on all your guys's hard work
for the for the contest
thanks for stopping by and learning
something new really appreciate y'all
um so next week who knows what we're
doing next week
i gotta figure that out usually i
figured out like the day of it's
stressful
it's very stressful i gotta get a better
uh
better setup and situation for figuring
out the streams
but i know that
we need to figure out the next weekly
challenge
right now all right so i'm gonna leave
it to you guys what do you guys
what do you guys want to do what do you
guys want to learn what do you guys want
to work on
this week what's it going to be what is
it going to be
jesse no worries you're gonna you're
gonna help us figure out
the weekly challenge and you can watch
the video over again it's all good
it'll be on youtube forever okay so
satisfying loop we did that
music i like that a lot
i'm a pocket that one for a second
spaceship initial d
alright sweet robot we did robot last
year
sports and athletics could be
interesting
um the election i think we can stay away
from the election
we get enough of that uh custom disney
character
dreams okay okay
um sadan where should you submit the
renders you can submit the renders
on my discord server down below there's
a link it's called join the community
um in there you'll see the whole like
challenge
uh like channel chunk whether there's
like a tree of like challenge channel
server or
this is what happens when you just talk
a lot for two and a half hours straight
you lose your mind yeah the link's in
the description it's the discord
all right dreams is nice sotomante our
very own moderator
he says he likes dreams what do you guys
think about dreams
dreams thumbs up or thumbs down
jesse what is dreams dreams would be the
potential theme for
this week's weekly challenge
ismail what kind of dream that's up to
you
that's for you to decide so we're going
to mix we're getting some thumbs ups
some thumbs downs but you know we can't
please everybody
i think we got a healthy amount of
thumbs ups
and you know we can always figure out
next week too we got
52 no 50 we got like 49 more challenges
this
this year it's gonna be a good time all
right guys dreams it is
we're doing dreams that is the challenge
for this week's theme you got to render
something
along the lines of a dream that's your
prompt
uh don't follow a tutorial and post that
as your submission you will get uh
dq'd for that do not
um plagiarize anyone else's work
it's happened in the past it's crazy i
know
don't do that it'll get you banned from
the server um
especially that there's going to be a
prize i'm giving away my service
imperfection pack
to the five winners who win this next
one
alright so no cheating
no doing tutorials and posting that as
your result alright
no you can use any program you want i
don't care how you
use or how you create the art you make
you just need to create the art that's
the whole point right
um anything else when you submit your
work on the discord
please name your image as your discord
name
it helps me with the the posting process
i'm gonna go
after the stream i'm gonna go and post
all the winners on the discord
so it helps me with that so please do
that just read the rules you'll see it
in the
in the uh weekly challenge
channel it'll make sense
um it can be a video but definitely post
a picture
um with it as well it needs it needs
like the one
image it can be a video as you saw uh
you can do video
yeah yeah and that's it
all right y'all um if you have any
questions for me i'll be here for the
next like
three to five minutes hanging out so
it's yeah it's a good time good first
stream so thank you guys and thank you
uh to 3d export definitely check them
out
um they're super super cool service
um yeah they give you a lot of a lot of
nice models
not a lot of light yeah it's the end of
the end of that stream time you know how
it goes
a lot of nice textures and they even
have tutorials too so check them out
guys
thank you to 3d export for making this
one happen
jesse yep this is the first stream of
the year
i did get engaged last year yeah last
year was it was a big one
got engaged and we got this place right
here so
good times what are my thoughts on 3d
printing i've never done it but it's
really cool
ren is really good at it advice for
beginner vfx
um follow the tutorials that pique your
interest
that keep your spark going
videocopilot.net is a great place for
after effects tutorials um
grayscale gorilla is great for cinema 4d
tutorials that's how i learned
and blender guru is a great place for
blender tutorials
uh that's how most of most everyone
learned blender
so follow the tutorials that really
speak to you and they're cool and that
are inspiring to you if you feel
yourself like
doing something and it's like ugh i
gotta do this
find that find the spark you know don't
make it a job yet don't jump into the
work of it
just keep it fun keep it creative and
passionate and keep learning
from there you know gather up a cool
body of work start taking the tutorials
and making them your own
because people can people can spot
tutorials
very easily so you want to start making
them your own that would be my next
piece of advice
all right what else you guys got um what
do you think about unreal engine
it's awesome i want to learn it this
year
very very exciting it's a very deep
program
very very deep program there's a lot to
get into
and it can be very overwhelming so just
uh
take your time and
keep your pace that's it that's my
advice
what else what else you guys got
claire just started learning c4d after
studying and working in 3ds max for
four years awesome yes i was in 3ds max
for around the same amount of time
and switched to c4d and love it so i'm
glad you are too
what about houdini um houdini's
craziness i'd rather learn unreal right
now than
than houdini if i'm going to spend a lot
of time learning something new
just because unreal i feel like is the
future it really is
jacob i'm about the same distance um
from corridor than i was at my last
place
yeah yeah it's not bad it's not bad at
all
have i used embergen i have not but ren
has
and it looks awesome i've never
well no i've used zbrush in the past
don't really use it too much i might get
into a little bit of it this year we'll
see though
what about maya they're all good guys
they're all good they're all awesome
there's no like one best program
it's really just what works best for you
that's it and what gets the best art out
of you but y'all
i think i think that's gonna be it i'm
gonna bounce out of here
um you guys have a fantastic weekend
have a good saturday have a good sunday
and i'll see you guys here next saturday
same place same time
and we will continue to learn and grow
together y'all
my name is clinton jones i'm the
punisher check out my other videos if
you guys want to keep learning
and i'll see you next time peace later
y'all
you